don't be afraid of the dark stars Katie
Holmes Guy Pearce and Bailey Madison it
was directed by Troy Nixie and produced
by Guillermo del Toro in case you guys
didn't know I love scary movies in fact
it's probably actually my favorite genre
of film it's just that so many of them
are so stupid that it's like really hard
to get into them it seems so rare that a
really good one comes along earlier this
year we had insidious and that was one
of the best scary movies I've ever seen
because it did exactly what a scary
movie supposed to do scare the crap out
of you but it was made really well and
acted very seriously despite the
ludicrous II of the plot so I was really
looking forward to this film because the
gamble Deltora really hyped it up at
comic-con he said it was really super
scary a little girl and her dad guy
Pierce moving into a new house
Katie Holmes as guy Pierce's girlfriend
and so there's a little bit of a family
tension there I'm not gonna give
anything away I'll just say there are
these things that exist in the basement
cellar and they like to cause a lot of
problems and it creates for a very
suspenseful movie that I had a lot of
fun with and really enjoy who are you
this movie was made very well it was a
really pretty film to look at and you
could tell del Toro had some of his
little touches in there because it
really looked a lot like some of his
films like Pan's Labyrinth
the acting in this film was a very high
caliber especially for a scary movie
particularly Bailey Madison the little
girl she was excellent in this movie see
when a child actor in a movie is really
the main star that's really a deal
breaker for me whether or not they're
gonna be good or bad because if they're
gonna be bad I mean they're just you
just gonna be annoyed by their acting
but she was excellent this movie I'm
really interested in seeing where else
she goes she was really good in the
movie brothers as well she's convincing
in all the emotional scenes she's funny
she's strong you really feel for her
character Katie Holmes I also really
enjoyed this film and I thought she did
a really nice job it's nice to see her
back at movies Guy Pearce I've always
loved and and his role in this movie was
kind of like James Franco's role and
Rise of the Planet of the Apes so what I
mean by that is that Franco's role in
the movie was necessary to propel the
story along but he really wasn't the
character you were with the rooting for
you were with Caesar and this movie guy
Pearce's character is necessary and he's
required for the story to progress but
you really with Bailee Madison scare
achter a lot more and so Guy Pearce kind
of gets pushed to the background a
little bit but for what his character
needed to be and for what he needed to
do he was good in the movie I also
really liked the things and the bass
when I thought they were really cool I
thought they were original I really
liked the way they looked
I thought the special effects were done
very well thank you we just had a
nightmare I'll be right here
now to some of the negative aspects for
me I don't know if it was this
particular print or the theater lighting
or what there were many scenes in this
film where it was way too dark and it
wasn't in 3d or anything so it wasn't
the dimness of the glasses there was
just some scenes we really couldn't tell
it was going on you need some more
lighting I don't know if that was
intentional in the filmmakers part
because obviously darkness plays a large
role in this film but here's really my
main problem with the film it wasn't
scary enough I didn't find it as scary
as it was hyped up to be for me I found
insidious considerably more frightening
I mean two very great extent I wasn't
terribly scared by it I don't know if I
just have really big manly balls or it
wasn't as scary as I thought it would be
I just felt like the director tried
Nixie he made a really good looking film
but I wanted him to scream more tension
out of these scenes and a lot of really
awesome potential in some of the scenes
for some serious suspense but because of
quick editing's at times it wasn't as
suspenseful as it could have been I felt
that some of the scenes if dragged out a
little bit longer and it made a little
bit more slower pace with a more
suspenseful why was that room sealed up
something terrible happened in that
basement
Wow also the foam has a lot of cliches
family moves into a new house new house
has something scary in it only the child
is recognizing this scariness you know
they're just a lot of cliches like that
you know the child has to prove to the
big people and all that stuff and
because of that it didn't make this a
remarkable film for me however I still
really enjoyed the film and had a lot of
fun watching it thought that Billy
Madison was just excellent in the movie
and I really liked Katie Holmes
character don't tell me you believe it
does not mean it's not really
don't be afraid of the dark without
spoiling anything I will say that there
is an aspect to the film's conclusion
that left me kind of confused I don't
really understand what it was saying
I don't know but see the mood for
yourself I enjoyed the film I'm gonna
give don't be afraid of the dark Abby I
thought that it was a lot of fun it was
a little bit cliched and not as scary as
it should have been but I still enjoyed
the film so if you liked my review don't
be afraid of the dark subscribe to my
channel and get stuck menage